i'm
excited to introduce you the first
episode and we're introducing you that
show
from hollywood hills with the hollywood
sign right behind me
ron howard's home the director to my
right about 100 yards to my right
and it's exciting because this new show
will be providing you value
attainment and what valuetainment means
to us is what we came across we're
watching two minutes with pat
is two minutes with pat was really about
valuetainment valuetainment means
not provoking value combined with
entertainment
that's led to movement of dialogues and
discussions amongst people
regarding things that matter in our
lives and what we'll be doing
differently with this starting next week
is
the episodes won't be going out on
fridays it'll be different segments
going out on tuesdays
and thursdays on a weekly basis and with
that being said
i'm going to get right into it with you
to explain to you what it is to go from
being a rebel without a cause
to being a rebel with the cause i want
to introduce you
to the r3 formula so i have a question
for you
do you ever wonder what's the difference
between a
steve jobs jeff bezos or a larry page
a frank lucas mickey cohen
and a bernie madoff right because when
you think about both of them they're
both
extremely driven extremely hard working
but what is the main difference between
the two you see the difference is
one group broke the rules while the
other group
broke the laws there is a big difference
between doing those two things
but in order for you to do great things
in life at times
you must break the rules and by the way
every one of us out there since we were
kids we've been breaking the rules
you know some of the things we did as
kids that our parents don't know about
till today you remember those days
maybe a car you took your mom and dad
didn't know about they may not even know
about it
until today because we like people who
break the rules there's a certain
level of admiration that we have for
them now
every 80 years roughly 7 billion people
are replaced with 7 billion new people
but why is it that only a few people do
something big with their lives that the
world knows about
well i've come to a conclusion that at a
certain phase of our lives
as we age the older we get we are we are
confined by so many rules don't do this
and you have to live in this box and if
you do this it's bad and if you do that
you're a bad person and people may
create rumors about you so
we start becoming so scared about doing
certain things right
so we we we convince ourselves we're
living a happy life but we're really
living a content life we become content
with what we have we become content with
our capacity
and we don't aim to see what we can
really do with our lives
but the truth is all of us want to
strive for happiness
every one of us wants to live a happy
life tony shea from zappos described it
best
on three levels of happiness the lower
level he talked about is pleasure
most of us spend most of our lives
chasing
pleasure to makes us happy while it's
got the lowest
level of life expectancy what's pleasure
if i smoke a cigar i'm happy
if i have a drink of whiskey i'm happy
if i go watch a movie i'm happy for two
hours
again shortest lifespan second level of
happiness is passion
when i work out i'm happy i feel good my
body feels good
you know when i play guitar i'm
passionate about playing the guitar
i'm passionate about running i'm
passionate about hiking all those things
are good
but it's not the highest level of life
expectancy
you see those who want to do something
big with their lives the rebels with the
cause
they're seeking lifelong happiness and
the only way we get lifelong happiness
is with the last level of happiness
which is purpose
purpose is correcting an injustice
purpose is doing something that's never
been done before
purpose is making a difference in
people's lives and
those who want to do something big the
rebels with the cause are not
necessarily
trying to make it on a list of the
richest people 400
they're not trying to get a certain
trophy they're not trying to get a
certain
plaque they make it on those lists by
pure default it's something bigger than
that
for them so the second phase is to
become obsessed
with your cause you see in life we have
a lot of wasted obsessions
and we have a lot of worthy obsession
too often we spend too much of our lives
on wasted obsessions tv sports highlight
express
facebook twitter whatever you may call
it that's all
wasted obsession worthy obsession is
stemmed from the three things we talked
about earlier
what you hate what you love and what
bothers you
and the reason why that's so important
is because too often in life
we're too lazy we're too bored we have
nothing really going on this is one of
my favorite quotes is
mankind is lazy until something
catches our heart once it does you come
to
crossroad and that's phase three and
that crossroad is you having the courage
to make a bold decision in your life you
may say
i've met a lot of people that have
identified their cause i met a lot of
people that are obsessed about their
cause
but they're afraid of making a bold
decision why because you will be
ridiculed
you will be criticized you will be
condemned you won't please people and
guess what most people don't like that
but here's what happens once you make a
bold decision
based on your cause and you're obsessed
about that cause
once you do that your spirit enlarges
and you're introduced to a person you
have never ever met in your life before
to the point where your friends your
family your co-workers
will tell you i don't recognize you
anymore you're not the same anymore
something happened to your eyes man what
has gone into you
because you finally got the fire in your
belly to know what your cause is
what bothers you you've made a bold
decision and you have the opportunity
not to go out there and do something
that's never ever been done before so
what's the bad news
here's the bad news you will never ever
be like steve jobs jeff bezos
or larry page but you know what the good
news is
they will never ever be like you
once you identify what your cause is
they can never ever be like you
but the key is to add your signature
to the world that's our responsibility
with that being said
make sure you subscribe and share this
video with as many people as possible
it's my message of the week to you